Whoopi Goldberg's leaving Twitter so it  has been a little over a week since Elon  Musk took over Twitter and places it  it's a mess  he also suspended Kathy Griffin for  impersonating him on a parody account  that hasn't been the same without you I  I'm getting off  please don't I'm tired of now  having had certain kinds of attitudes  blocked and now they're back on and I  just I'm Gonna Get out no please please  please and if it settles down and I feel  more comfortable yeah maybe I'll come  back but I'm done it's only missed  there are people literally on Twitter  right now who believe things that Whoopi  Goldberg does not believe she's on The  View only with people who agree with her  all day long well see you later